marc les boyer voit le jour à la plaine
des palmistes pour la plupart des
réunionnais cette commune est agréable
quand été pendant les vacances scolaires
dit de changement d'ère car toute
l'année elle est beaucoup trop arrosée
et peu animé pour ce pas lui plainois si
la plus belle commune de l'île où il
fait bon vivre avec une grande
convivialité une réelle authenticité et
ce dans une nature généreuse
d'ailleurs la plaine n'est pas seulement
une commune et un canton c'est aussi son
terroir
là où il a vécu toute sa première en
france après des études au lycée leconte
de lisle
il devient instituteur et enseignent
dans différentes communes de l'île puis
il poursuit sa formation pour devenir
professeur de français au collège
l'enseignement secondaire exigent une
double discipline il opte pour
l'expression artistique plus
particulièrement les arts plastiques
un domaine qu'il connaît bien et qu'il
transmet avec sa passion à ses élèves et
qu'il faudra défendre en tant que vice
président du département délégué à
l'éducation à la culture et au sport
c'est en 1988 que marc luc boyer devient
maire de sa commune et conseiller
général de son canton du 25 septembre
1988 au 9 mars 2008 au sein de
l'institution départementale
il présidera les commissions du sport de
1991 à 1992 de l'éducation et mobilité
de 2001 à 2004 puis du 1er avril 2004 au
9 mars 2008
il occupera le poste de vice président
délégué à l'éducation à la culture et au
sport
reprenant son siège de maire en 2014 il
retrouve son poste de conseiller
départemental passion et enthousiasme
sont ses principales qualités
il aime les gens toujours à leur écoute
son credo savoir agir aujourd'hui pour
demain homme de terrain il sera un
fervent défenseur des atouts de la
plaine tels que le tourisme
l'élevage l'horticulture cultures
fruitières l'artisanat sans oublier le
développement des commerces des
équipements sportifs et culturels
les professions de santé toutes les
activités liées à l'évolution
démographique de sa commune décoré de la
légion d'honneur du mérite coloniale de
la médaille de la jeunesse et sports et
du prix départemental du mérite
cet homme d'engagement s'est fortement
investi en tant qu élue déléguée à la
culture dans la définition de la
politique culturelle du département et
de sa mise en oeuvre
il a ainsi contribuer à l'amélioration
des conditions d'accès aux arts et à la
culture pour tous les publics
parmi les initiatives départementale
prises ou soutenu lorsqu'il était à ce
poste peuvent être cités la mise en
oeuvre du fonds de transport pour les
visites des équipements culturels du
département entre les établissements
scolaires maternelles primaires et
collèges et les équipements culturels de
la collectivité
les concours d'écriture et de critiques
à l'attention des collégiens la mise en
oeuvre du plan départemental de la
lecture qui a permis d'aider les
communes à enrichir leurs collections et
de recruter des personnels qualifiés
le prix célimène concours de créativité
à destination des femmes artistes
amateurs qui vise à faire découvrir de
nouvelles expressions artistiques dans
le domaine des arts visuels le
déménagement des archives
départementales à champ fleuri dans de
nouveaux locaux adaptés
le programme des événements organisés à
l'occasion des 60 ans de la
départementalisation
il a également oeuvré pour que la
collectivité soit un partenaire attentif
du monde culturel et pour ce faire à
attribuer des aides directes aux
artistes et associations dans
pratiquement toutes les disciplines
artistiques musique danse chant théâtre
et pour les événements de la vie
culturelle festival manifestations
traditionnelles contribuer à la
diffusion de spectacles vivants par le
biais de l'odc gestionnaire des deux
théâtres départementaux de saint gilles
et de champ fleuri
enfin pour que le département prenne
toute sa place en tant qu acteurs de la
vie culturelle
il a particulièrement soutenu les
équipements culturels pour qu'ils
interviennent dans le champ de la
connaissance de l'histoire du patrimoine
de la biodiversité ainsi réaliser leur
mission scientifique de conservation
d'enrichissement des collections et à
élaborer une programmation de haut
niveau accessible à tous souvent
présenté comme un homme de culture
marc luc boyer s'est également beaucoup
investi dans le domaine sportif
fervent membres de la vie associative il
crée le club de football de la plaine
club qui dirigera jusqu'en 1988
également footballeur de bon niveau
régional
il a longtemps oeuvré à titre bénévole
au sein du comité directeur de la ligue
réunionnaise de football
au début des années 80 avant de faire
son entrée en politique au conseil
départemental
il a confirmé son rôle d'élu de
proximité en privilégiant des actions
dédiées au secteur des eaux
c'est sous sa présidence en 1991 et 1992
que la commission sport amiens
place plusieurs actions structurantes au
profit des écarts les jeux d eau
manifestation sportive d'envergure
permettant aux jeunes de cilaos de
l'entre-deux de trois bassins de la
plaine des palmistes de la plaine des
cafres de sainte-rose et de
saint-philippe de se rencontrer dans un
cadre convivial et de se mesurer dans
plusieurs disciplines sportives
ces jeux ont souvent coïncidé avec la
réalisation ou la rénovation des
équipements sportifs de proximité pour
les communes des hauts création d'une
équipe départementale d'animateur
sportif pour développer la pratique
sportive dans les écarts et accompagner
les associations et les clubs dans leur
projet structuration du tissu sportif
des petites communes avec la prise en
charge par le département d'une
formation organisée par le creps en vue
de promouvoir les postes d'encadrement
sportif les cadres diplômés ont été par
la suite recruté par les communes grâce
à un financement départemental dégressif
sur quatre ans en sa qualité de vice
président délégué à la culture et au
sport
entre 2004 et 2008 il a également
beaucoup travaillé pour la coopération
entre les îles de l'océan indien avec
notamment aux jeux des îles de l'océan
indien
il s'est investi dans la préparation des
athlètes réunionnais pour l'édition de
2007 à madagascar
rencontre à paris avec les kréopolitains
et la représentation du à la
collectivité au jeu de madagascar
aujourd'hui il laisse son poste de
conseiller départemental à son suppléant
pour se consacrer plus particulièrement
à sa commune la présidente et les élus
du département tiennent à remercier et à
féliciter cet homme politique pour son
dynamisme son investissement et son
engagement comme il le disait lui même
quand on lui posait la question suivante
quelle est la recette d'un tel dynamisme
marc luc boyer répondait alors sourire
aux lèvres il n'y a pas de recette sinon
la passion et l'enthousiasmé pour ce que
l'on fait c'est une position qui exige
des contacts l'amour des gens et l'amour
de son pays